les bateaux je ne peux pas les ramener
au bord du ponton les nettoyer je peux
pas démarrer les moteurs je peux rien
faire on l'appelle la mère des Sargasses
mais en fait c'est une immense île
flottante constituée d'algues brunes qui
dérivent en permanence sur l'océan
Atlantique
les bonnes années elles restent au large
loin des Caraïbes les mauvaises années
des quantités phénoménales de Sargasses
viennent s'échouer sur les plages les
côtes et font fuir les touristes
ça vous prend la gorge ça vous pique les
yeux c'est un comodo vous avez envie de
vomir c'est en 2011 qu'on a observé la
première méga poussée de croissance des
Sargasses un phénomène qu'on s'explique
encore mal cette année nouvelle surprise
elle progresse plus rapidement que
jamais en décembre sa superficie est
encore modeste en janvier un peu moins
et en février elle a explosé pour
atteindre plus de 7000 km de longueur
qui est cyclique il y a des années où il
y a beaucoup plus d'accumulation que
d'autres avec les changements
climatiques qui s'accélèrent on ne sait
pas qu'elles vont être les répercussions
sur les changements de courant les
changements de vent qui sont aussi à
l'origine de ces accumulations même si
le pays reste à venir disent les experts
la vague brune a déjà fait des victimes
parmi les destinations chouchous des
Québécois Cancun tout loom et certaines
plages du sud-est de la Floride par
exemple
on prévoit d'ailleurs qu'il faudrait
rarement céder des millions de tonnes
d'algues décomposées et puantes durant
les prochains mois
rappelons cependant que les Sargasses
sont indispensables à plusieurs formes
de vie marine les jeunes tortues par
exemple les utilisent pour se cacher et
se nourrir les radeaux de Sargasses
et sont très importants pour que toute
une faune c'est des radeaux qui
permettent à plusieurs poissons de se
reproduire en temps normal la mère des
Sargasses couvre une superficie de 3
millions de kilomètres carrés au large
des Caraïbes ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal
direction Guadeloupe où on parle à
Pascal Jean Lopez vous êtes chercheur à
Pointe-à-Pitre alors est-ce que chez
vous est-ce que ça fait presque le tour
de l'île
[Musique]
alors pourquoi il y en a autant comme ça
a été très bien dit effectivement dans
un petit reportage avant donc on envoie
depuis 2011 et on voit effectivement que
les quantités s'accumulent presque de
façon constante d'année après année et
donc 2018 c'est juste pour revenir sur
les chiffres 2018 était une année au
corps ou non estimé après de 20 millions
de tonnes de Sargasses présents en 2018
et
2023 devrait être une très bonne année
un très grand cru effectivement pour les
Sargasses avec des quantités très
impressionnantes qui arrivent donc il y
a eu des irrégularités mais globalement
il y en a presque de plus en plus bon et
les gens nous parlent des odeurs de du
côté presque toxique qu'est-ce qu'on
peut en dire
ah oui alors ça c'est très très
impressionnant du coup les Sargasses
quand même se décomposent quand elles
ferment plus très faction des
paragraphes ça fait deux gaz principaux
qui sont le sulfure d'hydrogène H2S
l’œuf pourri tout le monde connaît
l'odeur et puis aussi des dégagements
d'ammoniac en fait un H3 et donc c'est
ces gaz acide et nauséabondes qui vont
effectivement irriter les muqueuses et
entraîner effectivement de certains
gènes respiratoires très importantes
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que
Jean Lopez qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
affronter cette cette vague brune
alors il y a deux choses effectivement
ce qu'on fait c'est d'une part essayer
de prévenir parfois l'arrivée sur les
côtes et une fois qu'elles sont sur les
côtes et ben on essaye de les enlever
pour rendre notamment les cotes
accessibles et puis les déplacer sur des
sites de stockage où on les laisse
globalement se décomposer mais pour
limiter c'est de limiter l'impact sur
les populations alors ça c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec les actes qu'est-ce
qu'on peut en faire oui de sésame que
c'était peut-être une partie de la
question et alors il y a beaucoup de
choses qui sont en cours d'études il y a
rien
d'aujourd'hui de révolutionnaire en fait
qui va marcher mais pour citer ce qui a
été fait et qui étudié c'est les
utiliser en compostage comme coproduit
utiliser la matière organique de ces
algues pour faire de l'amendement pour
essayer d'enrichir les sols on essaye à
réfléchir à en faire des plastiques des
plastiques à base de d'algues ça se
développe aujourd'hui il y a des voix de
valorisation sous la forme de papier ou
alors même tout simplement sous la forme
de Monsieur
on fait des briques globalement avec des
Sargasses dedans pour essayer de les
éliminer en fait c'est pour ça il
faudrait conséquent qu'il y a des
usines qui a des usines de
transformation faudrait ce qui n'est pas
le cas actuellement
oui c'est ça c'est le point essentiel
effectivement je crois que que vous
soulevez là aujourd'hui c'est pas qu'il
y a pas ça notamment parce que l'arrivée
est pas forcément prédictible et donc
avoir un business plan sur une ressource
qui est hétérogène ça reste relativement
difficile et puis la plupart des pays et
des îles des Caraïbes c'est des petites
îles en fait donc le développement
c'est un problème effectivement assez
sérieux pour l'ensemble de la Caraïbe et
puis du bloc du Mexique on le disait
c'est cyclique est-ce que en terminant
parce que Jean Lopez on peut espérer que
dans deux ans où l'an prochain ça soit
une année vraiment une petite année
point de vue Sargasses
alors les prédictions d'une année sur
l'autre aujourd'hui on peut pas le faire
mais ce qu'on sait les évidences qu'il y
a c'est que globalement les algues
Sargasses c'est des algues et plus on
leur donne à manger plus elles sont
capables de pousser et donc l'une partie
effectivement qui explique la présence
de ces algues c'est de l'anthropisation
du milieu marin et donc c'est la porte
de nutriments la porte d'azote qui sont
effectivement des écoulements et des
usages de nos jours en fait et donc
c'est effectivement ça qui explique
aujourd'hui au moins en partie la
présence ces explosions massives
d'algues la mer qui est fâchée les
océans qui sont fâchés contre nous et
voilà la réponse parce qu'à Jean Lopez
je rappelle le directeur de recherche au
Centre national de la recherche
scientifique
vous êtes à Pointe-à-Pitre en Guadeloupe
merci beaucoup
merci à vous au revoir